rescue workers in gaza dig through
rubble for survivors at the shatty
refugee camp
after a house there was hit by an
israeli airstrike
it's my cousin's house we were surprised
by an airstrike that hit the house
without any warning
we ran outside we saw the four-story
house get completely demolished
it was completely leveled his sister and
her kids were visiting
they were all killed all of them this
two-month-old baby called omar was one
of two survivors who were rushed to
hospital
but at least five other children were
killed
we are still trying to recover more
bodies and figure out who is who
this is truly a massacre that cannot be
described in words
we don't know how he managed maybe he
just stayed alive to be a witness of
what happened to the rest of his family
israeli jets tanks and artillery
attacked other sites across gaza on
friday
including a bank as well as the interior
ministry
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu says the bombardment of gaza
will not end anytime soon
the senior leaders of hamas believe that
they can escape from our armed forces
but they cannot
we can reach them everywhere we reach
all these people and we will continue to
do so
they attacked us on our holiday in our
capital and fired rockets at our cities
they have paid and will pay a heavy
price for that
this is not over yet
hamas and its allies responded to
friday's attacks by firing a barrage of
rockets from inside gaza
the israeli military said most were
intercepted
as the fighting continues the
humanitarian crisis in gaza grows
steadily worse
dozens of children have been killed
since the shelling began
and hundreds more have been displaced
with their families
aid workers say many palestinian
children are already traumatized by past
wars
this is why it's so critical that we
have to have an immediate ceasefire and
a cessation of hostilities these
children will carry
lifelong injuries mental health issues
in both physical
trauma and physical disabilities as well
palestinians are sheltering where they
can but they say nowhere in gaza
feels safe right now victoria gatenbee
al jazeera